[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens formidable que son
bien par rapport à d'autres villes
quelle île new york au pays en europe à
madrid
votre elle en pense quoi mon frère
qu'elle frère qui habite à new york
times il en veut fermer ou dit qu'est ce
qu'il y oppose eu mon frère pourquoi mon
frère je suis pas là non c'est et qui
sait encore comment ça va mon frère et
moi je trouve un rer un bus
surtout ne pas utiliser un bien trop
quand je veux pour aller aux jeux et
votre à elle en pense quoi
mon fère s'est vu mon frère il ya
peut-être quelque chose
bon donc les transports en commun
parisiens il n'en pense pas grand chose
à [ __ ] ok la couture pas bien fait là
j'ai vécu un peu partout dans le monde
amérique du sud en amérique du nord en
asie du sud est et tout sa fin dans tous
ces pays là mais je trouve que c'est pas
mal et votre elle en pense quoi
mon autre frère c'est plaisanterie ça
roule assez le truc si l'on pense quand
votre truc non truc chez adidas suite
c'est derrière moi je me suis fait
piéger ses calicots balle je sais pas
moi j'en sais me demande lui et sur les
transports en commun c'est ça c'est la
connerie j'avais un bon jour à ba ba a
pressé pour seulement
[Musique]
allez merci merci
[Applaudissements]